former vice president joe biden is
apologizing for comments he made about
african-american
voters on friday the presumptive
democratic nominee was trying to make a
case for why black americans should vote
for him rather than president trump
the remarks sparked outrage on social
media and even led the trump campaign
to start marketing a t-shirt
highlighting the apparent gaff
ed o'keefe reports joe biden is on the
defensive after making the racially
insensitive comments
really unfortunate cavalier his remarks
came friday in an interview with
influential black radio host
charlemagne the god but i tell him if
you have a problem figuring out whether
you're for me or
trump and you ain't black it don't have
nothing to do with trump it has to do
with the fact i want something for
my community that brought immediate
criticism from black republicans
including south carolina senator tim
scott
and john james a republican u.s senate
candidate from michigan
do you really believe that a black
person who doesn't vote for you is
therefore not legitimately black
cbs news polling shows biden is
supported by nine and ten
african-american voters
many are standing by him but his great
dollar's concern
weakness his greatest strength is being
kind of a gut
off the cuff politician and in this
moment it really jumped up to hurt him
biden has said he's considering several
black women for vice president
the list includes florida congresswoman
val demings
for cbs this morning saturday ed o'keefe
washington